they love their club they just hate the
club's owners
this vicious civil war at old trafford
sparked by the glazer family's part
in the super league project has the
players and the manager
stuck in the middle i've been
communicating with uh with the owners
i've got an apology
personally they've apologized
to to the fans how this came out it is a
difficult position to be in for me this
because i i've got to focus on the
football and it's uh
i've always had a good relationship and
they listen to me and
um they listen to the they do listen to
the fans
and i'm sure there'll be uh
there'll be better communication coming
it hasn't started quite yet
avraham glazer was unwilling to answer
anything
when sky news spoke to him in florida do
you have anything to say to manchester
united fans mr glazer
is it time to sell the club mr glazer
nothing to say at all are the fans just
customers to you
is the customer always right mr glazer
nothing to say at all to the fans of
manchester united mr glazer
this is an opportunity for you
an apology perhaps
fan groups have now organised a boycott
of the club's sponsors
they're having a concerted effort to try
and hurt the reputations of some of the
big businesses
that sponsor this club whether it's
boycotting their products
or trying to damage their reputations
online
the fans believe it's gone past the
point of trying to work things out
i think it's only going to get more
intense and and hopefully
um it's gonna it's gonna end it's gonna
end good for us and i hope that we don't
see any more violent news we don't have
to be violent with it
but at the same time i think we're going
to get louder not quite
if the glazers are to change tack and
try to bring the fans on
side they would need compromise instead
the next protests are already being
planned
tom parmenter sky news manchester